Das muss eine unfassbare Informationsdichte sein.
Das ist so viel Speicherplatz, wie
eine Trilliarde Mal das ganze Internet.
Und vor allen Dingen, würden das Zehnjährige
mit sich in der Hosentasche rumtragen.
Tach zusammen, Jack Pop hier!
Und Anne!
Anne ist heut nicht nur dabei, weil sie
Physikerin ist, sondern tatsächlich auch der
krasseste Pokémon Fan, den ich kenne. Simon und
Chris haben unter einem unserer letzten Videos
die wichtigste Pokémon Frage von allen gestellt.
Wie kann es eigentlich sein, dass so ein Pokémon
in so einem kleinen Ball reinpasst?
Pokémon können mehrere hundert Kilo
wiegen. Da war ich zuerst auch skeptisch.
Aber diesmal sagt die Physik nicht Nein,
Pokémon passen wirklich in Pokébälle.
Das schauen wir uns gleich an. Und der
erste logische Gedanke, den man hat, ist
ja, dass die Pokémon in den Pokébällen
halt einfach irgendwie geschrumpft werden.
So wie Ant-Man auch schrumpfen kann. Das haben
wir beide ja schon zusammen durchgespielt.
Die Folge dazu verlink ich Euch hier oben.
Das liegt natürlich mega nah. Aber das Schrumpfen
basiert darauf, dass das Atom fast komplett leer
ist, weil der Abstand zwischen Atomkern und
Elektron so groß ist. Wir könnten jetzt sagen
nach der Pokéball den Abstand verringern kann.
Dann wäre das Pokémon zwar klein genug und würde
bequem in den Ball passen. Aber es wäre immer
noch genauso schwer, weil die Masse gleichbleibt.
Das heißt, wir haben ein Gewichtsproblem.
Und das hat mir auch Daniel vom Kanal
PokémontutorialTV erklärt. Und er hat dazu
sogar noch eine konkrete Szene rausgesucht.
Hey Anne, hey Jack!
Schrumpfen ist auch das erste,
woran ich gedacht habe. Vor allem, weil die
Pokébälle im Manga ein wenig anders aussehen.
Da ist die eine Hälfte durchsichtig und man sieht
eine Mini-Version von die Pokémon, was drin ist.
Aber im Anime sehen wir, dass das nicht die Lösung
sein kann. Denn das Gewicht ist tatsächlich der
Knackpunkt. Denn wenn selbst ein Zehnjähriger, wie
Ash, mit sechs Pokémon in der Tasche herumrennt,
dann können die nicht ein paar dutzend- oder sogar
ein paar hundert Kilo wiegen. Und das Pokémon,
wenn sie im Pokéball sind, so gut wie
nichts wiegen, dafür gibt es sogar ein
Beweis. Und der ist in dieser Szene hier.
(Onyx Du bist zu schwer, komm wieder rein!)
Hier sieht man deutlich, wie der Zeppelin
sinkt, als Rocco das Onyx aus dem Ball lässt
und dann wieder steigt, als er es einfängt.
Welche Physik da jetzt dahinter steht,
kann ich Euch nicht sagen. Fest steht aber,
dass die Pokébälle in einer Pokéball-Fabrik
hergestellt werden. Leider aber über die
genauen Bestandteile nichts bekannt ist.
Das könnte jetzt sicherlich besser beurteilen.
Deswegen spiele ich den Pokéball zurück zu Euch.
Daniel vielen Dank. Und es gibt ja auch total
Sinn. Denn wenn wir uns das Pokémon-Fangen
anschauen, dann sieht man nicht, wie
die irgendwie schrumpfen oder kleiner
werden. Wir sehen eigentlich immer nur Licht.
Eine mögliche Theorie ist, dass die Pokémon
über den Ball irgendwohin teleportiert werden.
Wie in der Serie als, als Ash Krabbi fängt,
sein Team schon voll ist und es dann
zu Professor Eich teleportiert wird.
Nur dass die Pokémon im Team dann eher in eine Art
Arbeitsspeicher komme und nicht zu Professor Eich.
Teleportieren würde uns auf jeden
Fall total gut stehen. Das ist ja
spätestens seit Start Trek und dem Beamen ein
richtiger Science-Fiction-Klassiker. Und zu
Star Trek haben wir auch schon eine eigene
Folge gemacht. Die verlinke ich Euch hier.
Wenn man es genau nimmt, gibt es einen
Unterschied zwischen Teleportieren und
Beamen. Beim Teleportieren wird etwas
von einem Ort zum anderen transportiert,
ohne den Raum dazwischen zu durchqueren. Beim
Beamen ist das anders. Da wird Materie in Energie
umgewandelt und so transportiert. Aber jetzt
der Downer. Teleportieren im klassischen Sinne
funktioniert erst mal nicht.
Aber warum nicht?
Megaschade! Aber das Problem ist, dass
Teleportieren direkt gegen mehrere
Naturgesetze verstößt, zum Beispiel gegen den
Energieerhaltungssatz. Vereinfacht können wir uns
das mit Abra hier vorstellen. Das ist ja bekannt
für die Attacke Teleport. Und jetzt, gerade wo
es hier im Baum sitzt, hat es nur potenzielle
Energie. Das heißt auch Lageenergie und ist die
Energie von dem Moment, indem er hochgeklettert
ist. Die ist gespeichert jetzt in potenzieller
Energie. Wenn Abra jetzt aber herunterklettert,
dann wandelt es potenzielle Energie in kinetische
Energie, also Bewegungsenergie um. Hier unten
hat es weniger potenzielle Energie. Aber dadurch,
dass die potenzielle Energie von oben umgewandelt
wurde, ist die Gesamtenergie erhalten geblieben.
Und das wäre beim Teleportieren ja anders,
weil da würde das Ganze instand passieren.
Abra kommt instand vom hohen Baum runter auf die
Erde und Energieerhaltungssatz funktioniert nicht
mehr. Wo ist die Energie hin? Also da müssen wir
ganz klar sagen: Teleportation ist leider raus.
Unsere letzte Hoffnung ist also das
Beamen. Anne das musst du uns mal
erklären. Was ist da jetzt anders?
Beim Beamen wird der Raum zwischen den
Orten durchquert und zwar in Form von Strahlung.
Das heißt, das Pokémon würde dann in Strahlung,
zum Beispiel Licht, umgewandelt werden. Mit
Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Ziel transportiert
und dann da wieder materialisiert.
Das ist physikalischer prinzipiell
machbar. Also Energie in Materie
umwandeln und umgekehrt. Das ist möglich.
Ja. Und wenn wir es genau nehmen, dann ist Materie
und Energie das gleiche. Vielleicht habt ihr schon
mal von E=mc² gehört. Energie gleich Masse mal
Lichtgeschwindigkeit zum Quadrat. Das ist die
Formel, die Einstein berühmt gemacht hat. Und
wenn wir uns jetzt nur die Formel angucken,
dann wirkt das irgendwie so, als könnten
wir beliebig aus Energie Materie machen
und anders rum. Aber eigentlich brauchen
wir dafür ganz bestimmte Bedingungen.
Und das ist auch gut so, denn sonst würden
ja permanent irgendwelche Gegenstände zu
Energie zerfallen. Oder aus Licht wird
plötzlich ein Klumpen Lehm. Das geht nicht.
Aber wo das gerade jetzt in diesem Moment
passiert, ist zum Beispiel im Inneren der
Sonne. Denn da entsteht durch Kernfusion, also dem
Verschmelzen von zwei Atomkernen, Strahlung und so
verliert die Sonne in jeder Sekunde 4 Milliarden
Kilogramm an Masse die dann zu Licht werden.
Aber bevor er jetzt gleich denkst, die
Sonne ist gleich weg. Das klingt mega viel,
aber die Sonne hat insgesamt eine Masse von
zweimal zehn hoch 30 Kilogramm, das sind
200 Milliarden Milliarden Milliarden Kilogramm.
Das bedeutet, das was sie pro Sekunde verliert,
ist komplett vernachlässigbar. In den viereinhalb
Milliarden Jahren, die wir schon existiert,
hat sie nicht mal ein Promille Gewicht verloren.
Das heißt, die bleibt uns noch ein paar Milliarden
Jahre erhalten. Und klar wird, dass das Prinzip
funktioniert, und zwar nicht nur in der Sonne,
sondern auch hier auf der Erde. Zum Beispiel
in Atomkraftwerken Da nicht über Kernfusion,
sondern über Kernspaltung. Aber auch da wird
aus Atomen heraus Energie gewonnen. Zwar unter
ganz bestimmten Bedingungen, technischen Hürden,
und auch in der Sonne haben wir ja einen extrem
hohen Druck und hohe Temperaturen. also
das braucht schon diese ganz speziellen
Situationen. Und es ist ja auch nicht so, als
könnte man das in seinem Kinderzimmer nachmachen
und jede beliebige Schildkröte plötzlich in
Energie umwandeln. Das heißt, die Pokébälle
müssten schon das eine oder andere Problem lösen.
Ja, dabei entsteht nämlich wirklich wahnsinnig
viel Energie. Lass uns zum Beispiel mal Togepi in
Energie umwandeln. Es hat eine Masse von 1,5kg und
die Lichtgeschwindigkeit sind 300.000km/s.
Wenn wir das jetzt im Quadrat einsetzen,
bekommen wir eine Energie von 135 Billiarden
Joule. Das ist in einer Größenordnung von
einer Atombombe. Und diese Energiemenge
muss man erstmal kontrollieren können.
Es ist auch technisch überhaupt nicht machbar.
Und vor allen Dingen, das muss ein Zehnjähriger
irgendwie in der Hosentasche mit sich herumtragen.
Und noch komplizierter wird dann der
Umkehrprozess, wenn wir nämlich aus Energie wieder
Togepi machen wollen. Denn aus Licht Materie
herzustellen ist wahnsinnig energieaufwendig.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum das erst in
diesem Jahr tatsächlich geklappt hat. Da haben
Forschende am Brookhaven National Laboratory in
New York dieses Papier veröffentlicht. Allein
an der langen Liste an Namen sieht man schon,
wie aufwendig das gewesen sein muss. Die haben es
nämlich tatsächlich geschafft, aus zwei Photonen,
also zwei Lichtteilchen, Materie werden zu lassen,
nämlich ein Positron und ein Elektron. Und obwohl
die Theorie zu diesem Experiment schon seit
1934 bekannt ist, hat es fast 90 Jahre gedauert,
bis das in diesem Jahr tatsächlich stattgefunden
hat. Die Forschenden haben das Experiment nämlich
an einem Teilchenbeschleuniger gemacht. Die
Technik hat das früher einfach nicht gegeben
und der Teilchenbeschleuniger, den die benutzt
haben, hat einen Umfang von vier Kilometern.
Und außerdem zieht der verdammt viel Strom.
Die Leistung ist ungefähr 340 Megawatt. Das
ist der Energiebedarf von einer Großstadt.
Damit können wir festhalten, dass der Prozess
tatsächlich in beide Richtungen möglich ist
und auch schon durchgeführt wurde. Das heißt,
die Pokémon kommen in den Ball rein und auch
wieder raus. Damit stehen dem Pokéball zumindest
erst mal keine Naturgesetze im Weg, höchstens
vielleicht ein paar technologische „Feinheiten“.
Aber in der Pokémon-Welt gibt es ja ganz viele
Pokémon-Professorinnen und –Professoren. Die
werden das schon irgendwie gelöst bekommen
Eine Kleinigkeit ist da aber noch. Und zwar
müsste der Pokéball auch so eine
Art Bauanleitung speichern. Damit,
wenn die Energie wieder zu Togepi wird, jedes
Atom wieder da ist, wo es auch vorher war.
Damit das Togepi am Ende auch
wieder exakt dasselbe Togepi wird.
Damit haben sich 2012 Studierende von der Uni
Leicester beschäftigt zwar nicht mit Pokémon,
aber mit dem Beamen von Menschen. Und die haben
ausgerechnet, wie viel Speicherplatz man braucht,
wenn man die Informationen über einen
ganz bestimmten Menschen speichern möchte.
Und das muss unfassbar viel sein. Denn wir müssen
uns ja vorstellen, wir müssten jede einzelne Zelle
abbilden. In den Zellen sind DNA-Informationen
drinnen, die wir auch alle irgendwie rüberbringen
müssten. Dann alles, was im Gehirn und im Kopf
vorgeht, also Erfahrungen, Erinnerungen, die über
neuronale Verbindungen abgebildet werden. Also
es muss eine unfassbare Informationsdichte sein.
Es ist wirklich unfassbar viel. Die sind grob
auf einen Speicherplatz von 2,6. Mal zehn hoch
42 bit gekommen. Das ist so viel Speicherplatz
wie eine Trilliarde Mal das ganze Internet.
Das heißt ein Pokéball muss nicht nur richtig
krass mit Energie umgehen können. Der muss
auch Informationen in unvorstellbarer
Größe handeln können. Das heißt, der
es eigentlich ein richtig fancy Speichermedium.
So jetzt haben wir eine schöne Erklärung für unser
Problem gefunden und dabei direkt Jun’ichi
Masuda, einen der Pokémon-Entwickler, beim
Flunkern erwischt. Der hat nämlich gesagt, dass
so ein Pokéball superbequem ist. Er hat gesagt,
„die sind fancy wie eine Hotelsuite“
und das haut dann in unserem Beispiel
nicht hin. Bei uns müsste der Pokéball eher
eine Mischung aus USB-Stick und Beamen sein.
Genau. Also der Pokéball muss wahnsinnig viel
Informationen und Energie in sich speichern.
Also das Pokémon in Form von Licht und die
Bauanleitung dazu. Und dann muss es dazu in
der Lage sein, kontrolliert Materie in Energie
umzuwandeln. Und andersrum. Und die Technik gibt
es leider heute bei weitem noch nicht.
Ja heute nicht, aber vielleicht in der
Zukunft. Und dann wäre unser Problem gelöst
und wir hätten ein Kindheits-Mysterium geklärt.
Und wenn wir das Ganze jetzt noch ein
bisschen weiterspielen und davon ausgehen,
dass nicht der Pokéball die Pokémon in Energie
umwandelt, sondern dass sie das selber können,
dann können wir nicht nur erklären, wie
sie in den Pokéball kommen, sondern auch
wie sie ihre Spezialattacken einsetzen.
Ja zum Beispiel, dass die Energie in
Wasser umwandeln - für die Aquaknarre.
Die können aus Energie dann einfach
alles machen. Feuer, Wasser, Rasierbaltt.
Ja das ist ziemlich cool. Und diese Theorie,
die können wir sogar noch einen Schritt
weiterdenken. Denn in den Pokémon-Spielen
ist es ja so, dass sie die Attacken nur begrenzt
oft einsetzen können und dann ins Zentrum müssen,
um sich zu heilen. Und jetzt wissen wir auch,
warum. Die Energie ist dann einfach verbraucht.
Und deshalb reicht es auch, die Pokébälle da
einfach nur so hinzulegen, im Pokémon-Center.
Weil die sich damit Strom aufladen.
Wie ein Handy in der Ladestation. Und
hättet Ihr gedacht, dass so viel versteckte Physik
in Pokémon drin ist? Ich finde, das sollte ab
sofort Pflichtprogramm im Physikunterricht
werden. Also Herr Schmidt, Frau Müller,
ab jetzt bitte immer Pokémon drannehmen.
Anne, vielen Dank fürs erklären - bitte
gerne. Und wir sagen Danke an Daniel vom Kanal
PokémontutorialTV. Den Link packe ich euch in
die Infobox, checkt das bitte aus und sagt uns
doch mal in den Kommentaren, wie euch diese Folge
gefallen hat. Auf jeden Fall nicht vergessen zu
abonnieren die Glocke zu drücken. Dann sehen wir
uns nämlich bald wieder, ich würde mich freuen!
(Anne, was hast
Du da eigentlich in Deinem Rucksack?)